something felt off I just felt like I
wasn't balanced bethenny frankel gets
emotional about her health scare Real
Housewives of New York star sat down
with ET at her home in Soho New York
Tuesday where she opened up about her
female health issues can you just kind
of tell us about your diagnosis and what
it is that you're going through I've
always experienced girly problems I had
endometriosis my whole life and I went
to the doctor and they said that I had
cysts and fibroids my doctor put me on a
really strong progesterone it's a lot of
hormonal stuff going on I was panicked
about just going into surgery right away
I you know going in and just being cut
open so I postponed it for a while and
try different things calm down a little
bit and I went to Aspen with my daughter
because it was her break and I really
didn't want to disappoint her or waste
the break the precious time I had with
her and um when I got there I had to the
hospital was that the scariest moment of
all this for you that was really bad
because I'd really like tried to hold it
all together and I didn't want it to
point her on this trip and I said I was
gonna really stay in the move in the
whole entire time anyway ah it was just
scary